today we're going to discuss the
difference between grass-fed burgers and
conventional burgers is it really worth
the extra cost because it is a bit more
expensive you know you'll see all sorts
of things on the label it's natural
right or it's natural beef and
handcrafted it's fresh
free-range 100% pure beef well these
things mean nothing legally okay ideally
if you can find it you don't just want
grass-fed you want one or percent
grass-finished okay now a lot of times
when you buy grass-fed beef if it
doesn't say grass-finished chances are
it was finished with grains and I always
wondered about this word finished what
does that mean it means fattened because
if you take a cow and you feed it just
grass it's gonna take a long time to
actually get it to be a thousand or
twelve hundred pounds it's much faster
to fatten the cattle and grains just
like we do with people right we put them
on the food pyramid as their diet so the
word finished means fattened and you
might think well is it gonna take a
couple weeks maybe a couple of months
actually it takes at least four months
okay I'm putting them on grains now if
it doesn't say organic then that means
it's GMO and this is really what I want
to talk about because when I talk about
GMO grains sometimes people just kind of
glaze over they don't even really know
what I mean so I do want to cover that
in just a second first let's cover how
many carbs are in a burger zero carbs so
that's totally keto friendly 14 percent
is protein you would think it'd be a lot
more right thirty percent is fat and
just about almost 50% of it is water
so you have all these things connected
with the burger being healthy or not is
it grass-fed is it organic there's an
antibiotics hormones preservatives are
you consuming the bun with that burger
are you adding ketchup the fries the
coke and all these things well of course
we're not going to recommend that but
the most important thing you need to
understand is this GMO thing and that's
want to cover next so what is GML it's a
genetic modification of something and
we're talking about grains primarily
corn and soy okay
so whether a cow is being finished or
fattened with corn or soy or it's a
factory farm and they're just consuming
corn in soy on a regular basis they're
being exposed to glyphosate now if it's
organic grains they're not being exposed
to glyphosate and this is another point
where people kind of glaze over the word
glyphosate what is this well it's a weed
killer okay
it's an herbicide and it's the same
chemical and Roundup Ready that you
would spray the weeds around your yard
here's what you need to know it's linked
with non-hodgkins lymphoma if you go to
Google right now and you type glyphosate
the first three ads are going to be
attorney ads and they're gonna ask a
question do you have non-hodgkins
lymphoma and there's all sorts of other
variations of this type of cancer and by
the way this is one of the most common
cancers in the US and it's also common
in UK and Canada and other parts of the
world because if you had this cancer it
could have been caused by exposure to
glyphosate right now in present time
there are over 9000 lawsuits involving
this one chemical the farms in the US
alone could use about a pound of
biphosphate for every acre of cropland
every year there is over 80 thousand
metric tons of glyphosate put into the
environment just in the u.s. that's
every single year the problem is that
this chemical is accumulative and it
does create problems in her body and
that go beyond just cancer so if you're
going to consume a conventional burger
maybe not do it as often so in summary
I'm not trying to scare you
I'm trying to increase your awareness on
GMO and the importance of doing
grass-finished okay
and organic thanks for watching so if
you want more knowledge on how to create
a healthy body subscribe now and get
daily notifications